hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well to affective
states that Aristotle discusses in the
Nicomachean ethics are closely connected
with friendship but are something
different than friendship one of them is
actually to a certain extent concluded
in friendship and one is you might say a
certain aspect of friendship playing
itself out within the political or
social realm and we translate those as
goodwill and Concord goodwill is and
would know something that Aristotle
talked about in book eight of the nick
of McKeon ethics it's something up that
he also talks about is very important in
the rhetoric as one of the key things
that gets people believed being able to
display Illinois or goodwill and Concord
is homeboy I'm literally having the same
news having the same mentality or they
were thinking about something so what I
put here these are both connected with
friendship but they're not the same as
friendship there they're distinct from
it if we look first at a good wittle'
now Aristotle talked about this in in
book eight and what he has to say in
book nine is sort of springboarding off
of that goodwill is an element of
friendship
so that it you know it's important that
friends actually desire the good for
each other but we're good we'll differs
from friendship is that you can feel
good will towards people without
actually knowing them and Aristotle
gives the examples of for example
watching athletes compete in a crowd of
course a damn television but I think
television is even better we're talking
about how mediated this is you know you
may be sitting in a bar watching the
game play and you know you're rooting
for your team but you don't really know
them even though you know people have
put profiles of them and you know this
guy's the underdog and this guy is
recovering from an injury or whatever it
is that you want you feel a sense of
goodwill for them you want them to win
not just because you put money on in
your prestigio that's a you generally
genuinely desire the good for them you
could even feel that towards the other
team although you know people might see
you as a traitor as a result but you're
not friends with them because it's not
reciprocated I mean they could have a
vague sense of goodwill and want all my
fans to do well but it's not anything
that's that's at the level of a real
connection between you and as a matter
of fact Arizona says that the good
wittle' that one person feels towards
another person might not even be known
to the recipient so that's very
different than fresher in which there
has to be not only good will you know
from one person to the other has to be
reciprocated it also has to be known so
friends know each other to be friends
people who have goodwill towards each
other don't necessarily know that to be
the case and he says a few other
interesting things along this lines he
says it also has no intensity nor does
it include
the same kind of desire but these things
are necessarily involved in a faction
Phil aces right so it's not as intense
it doesn't have the kind of you might
say commitment right and like I could
hear the person as Aristotle says
desires the good for the other person
but they're not committed to doing
anything about it so as Aristotle will
tell us some spectators conceived
goodwill and sympathy for the
competitors in a contest but they're not
about to do anything because of it he
says a little bit later they merely
desire the good of those whose
well-wishers they are and would not
actively assist them to attain it or put
be put to any trouble on their behalf so
you know when you think about what goes
into say clicking like on somebody's
post that might be an expression of
goodwill rather than and being friends
all the facebook calls you friends quite
often when you when you're doing that
sort of thing doesn't it but Facebook
friends are not necessarily friend Senor
astute ilion sense they could just be
people who feel good will towards each
other or they might actually be people
who feel a kind of fact simulated
conquered as we'll talk about in a
moment so every symbol is willing to say
that goodwill is perhaps the beginning
of friendship e says if people do feel
good will for each other and then
discover that that's the case they can
you know add all the other components of
friendship in and thereby become friends
but the mere fact of having good will
towards each other in all the speaker
displays towards his audience in the
rhetoric right is not the same thing as
being friends even if you call each
other friends so that's an interesting
departure what about Concorde homo neue
Aristotle says this has to do with
sharing the same opinions dokes i right
but it's
not just any sort of opinion and he
tells us why that's the case he says
it's not her agreement in opinion at all
because this might exist among strangers
so you know people that you don't know
on the other side of the world might
actually think the same things as you
about you know Indian dishes or about
the follow the Roman Empire are you know
all sorts of things like that and then
the internet is great for fighting those
sorts of things out but that doesn't
mean that you have with an actual
Concord with them he also goes out he
says nor is it about just any subject
matter whatsoever for X for instance
kind of astronomy to agree about the
facts of astronomy is not a bond of
friendship right now of course you could
it be friends on the basis of you
looking at telescopes all the time I'm
going to the planetarium sending each
other articles about the latest thing
that's been discovered but that's not
quite the same thing as they ourselves
talking about here is talking about
agreement in opinions and so what kinds
of opinions would actually bring us
together in this state that he calls
Concord well it has to do with what is
useful for us it's we agree about the
total fare on the useful that which has
utility that which is helpful the
opposite of which is the harmful right
yeah the other things that we agree
about or want to choose you talked about
us choosing in the sense of prior ases
we have another video about that if you
have any questions about Croesus you
talks about us having the same prior
asus and being in agreement about that
we commit the same way we choose the
same way we might think about this in
terms of you know political arrangements
as we'll get to his examples in a moment
also how to do it how to implement it
what actually
asked to be done and so what we're
looking at are the things that matter to
us aerosol talks in terms of politics
but I think we could also think in terms
of society where should the roads run
who should be in charge what kind of
fundamental way of doing things should
we have do we get on as we say on the
same page about those sorts of things in
that case we have Concord or are we
actually fighting each other about this
the opposite of Concord is what eres el
que haces which means something like
fashion or social breakdown this is
something that happened quite often in
your in ancient Greek city-states and I
think it's something that is you know
sort of like a permanent state within
our own political systems where we have
you knows rivalries constantly going to
doing town on the same issues now he
also tells us that if we understand it
in this way it's kind of a friendly
state between fellow citizens people who
have a stake in a political community we
might also think about this in terms of
organizations as well that there could
be a hobo neue or concord within an
organization when everybody is in
fundamental agreement about what want to
be done and who ought to be in charge
and where the company or the
organization a lot to be heading what
was what the point is and how it
implements that that point and so he
says that this primarily is going to
exist between good people who are able
to be friends with each other I'm not so
much between bad people he says you can
have a little bit of this but bad people
are going to be prone to you know
watching each other suspiciously to make
sure nobody goes over the lines nobody
does it there
not supposed to do so it's tougher for
bad people to be in this this state or
being you might say a community of Homo
neue the way that that good people can
so these two states are aerosol thanks
very important to discuss they're not
the same thing as friendship but they
are important within our moral life and
our experience so that is why he wants
to tell us about them and distinguish
them from friendship